m
c'est à la gare routière de saint benoît
que les accompagnateurs de la zone est
du réseau car jeunes ont organisé dans
le cadre de leur formation
une action d'information sur le civisme
dans les transports en commun tout au
long de la journée ils ont sensibilisé
les usagers aux règles du vivre ensemble
notamment vers les personnes à mobilité
réduite
pour ce faire ils ont mis en place un
stand en s'alliant avec une association
oeuvrant dans le milieu du handicap
alors on a organisé cette journée en
fait dans le cadre de notre formation
est dans notre contrat d'avenir en fait
on doit d'affaires une journée avec une
association dont on a décidé de près
cette journée en gare aux tirs comme
c'est notre lieu de travail
on a fait venir l'association handisport
pour les personnes à mobilité réduite
qui prennent le bus tous les jours ou
occasionnellement comme dans les
nouveaux bus il ya aussi des
emplacements réservés à ces personnes
donc on a organisé cette journée on a
profité de cette journée en fait pour
faire voir que le réseau maintenant il
est il a est disponible en fait pour les
personnes en difficulté si aussi des
améliorations proposées voilà c'est le
profit de cette journée aussi pour
prendre des notes
voilà ils sont là pour rappeler les
règles de politesse aussi les gens
arrivent avec les musiques tout ça de
l'est
cette alchimie nam dans les bus
doivent eux
ici c'est gratuit l'association
handisport a également profité de cette
action pour découvrir les aménagements
mis en place pour les personnes à
mobilité réduite et ainsi envisager des
améliorations si nécessaire aujourd'hui
par exemple nous avons les personnes qui
ont utilisé le transport
quelquefois on rencontre des difficultés
et aussi à ce niveau aujourd'hui
quand ils sortent du bus il n'y a pas la
sensibilité pour monter vers le guichet
des tickets cette journée à la gare
routière de saint benoît a permis de
réaliser une belle action de
communication pour une mobilité durable
et accessible à tous